these are the top five doomsday  scenarios that could destroy the world  jupiter turns into a star this would  completely disrupt and destroy nearly  everything in our solar system the moon  falls to earth the moon would be ripped  into millions of pieces as it got closer  to earth and the debris from this would  form rings around the earth like  saturn's our solar system gets sucked  into a black hole a supermassive black  hole that's at the center of our galaxy  could eventually suck up our entire  solar system a massive asteroid smashes  into earth this happened millions of  years ago when all the dinosaurs got  wiped out and it could happen again  making humanity go extinct  the sun expands and destroys us  this one's actually going to happen in  about 5 billion years the sun will  expand and turn into a red giant taking  out the earth in the process so